CHET HAASE: Hello.
I am not Romain Guy.
ROMAIN GUY: And I am
not Chet Haase.
That's a good thing, actually.
CHET HAASE: That's
what I think.
Welcome to "A Moving
Experience."
ROMAIN GUY: So we're going
to talk about animations.
CHET HAASE: Why are we going
to talk about animation?
So one of the questions
that people--
ROMAIN GUY: I know why.
That's because you cannot shut
up about animations.
CHET HAASE: I'm going to talk
about them because I--
ROMAIN GUY: You should
see him at work.
He's always like, animations,
animations, animations,
animations.
OK.
Now you can talk.
CHET HAASE: OK.
So I'm going to talk about them
because I enjoy talking
about them.
You are going to listen
to them--
Actually, I don't know why
you're listening them.
You should listen about
animations because I believe
they help create more compelling
applications.
They make applications maybe
more fun, but that's not the
real reason why it's actually
worth spending effort on.
ROMAIN GUY: They also
justify your salary.
CHET HAASE: They do
justify my salary.
So I wish you would write more
and more and require more
feature requests in the Android
platform, specifically
around animations.
Thank you.
One of the most important
reasons is to engage your
user, to actually connect them
to the application, make them
feel good about it, give them
a dynamic experience instead
of just some random
poorly-written page that they
click through in some
form that they hate.
Give them an experience from
your application that lets
them remember your application,
the experience
itself, and the precious quality
time that they spent
with it on their device.
In addition, it can help them
understand what can be a very
confusing user interface
experience, especially for
people like my mother.
If you can use animations to
help the user understand that
transitions and changes that are
actually happening in the
application and on the screen,
then it can be a very helpful
way to not only engage them and
keep them connected but
help them understand the flow of
your application in the way
that you want them to, alert
them in a way that they can
see on the screen of information
that they need to
know about, help them transition
from state to state
so they understand where they
came from and how they got
there so that they can stay
connected to the different
states in the application as
you're going through them.
ROMAIN GUY: So first we're
going to get started, and
we're going to talk about four
principles that are behind all
good animations.
The first one is keep your
animations short.
There is nothing more annoying
than when use an app and you
push a button, maybe
by mistake, and
then something happens.
We are a very impatient being.
Something that feels like it
takes 10 years on screen
actually might last for half
a second or just a second.
But when you didn't want that
animation, it's going to be
very painful.
Actually, it happened to us
in our previous session.
I was a little too impatient
because I had a slow animation
on one of the slides.
And I hit the arrow again, and
that skipped it to another
animation right after that.
So it can be very painful for
the users and can be very
painful for you as a developer,
because you'll have
to see that animation over
and over and over again.
I like to justify our principles
in that way.
Developers, that's going
to be painful for you.
Make it good for you,
it's going to be
good for the users.
CHET HAASE: Good.
Good.
ROMAIN GUY: To give you
an idea when you use a
ViewPropertyAnimator on Android,
we have a default
duration that, I think, is set
as, what, 300 milliseconds?
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
ROMAIN GUY: So 300 milliseconds
is a good
direction for a lot of
animations on a mobile device.
It's pretty short.
It's not too short that we won't
have enough frames to
see the entirety of
the animation.
And for most animation, it's not
going to annoy the user.
CHET HAASE: So one of the
dynamics here, actually with a
lot of this stuff, we don't
have an answer.
We can't say 300 milliseconds
is the duration that you
should use for all animations,
because that
answer would be stupid.
Because it really depends
on the situation.
If you're moving a view a very
short distance, I would expect
that animation to
be far shorter.
If it's something that you
expect to be almost an atomic
action, I would expect it
to be almost immediate.
But if you're moving a view, and
it's a large complex view,
and you're moving it from one
side of the screen on a large
tablet device down to the other
side of the screen,
bottom corner, well, maybe that
duration should be longer.
Make the duration appropriate
to the animation that's
actually happening
and no longer.
A really good example of this
is the window animation that
we use on the platform.
When you switch activities or
when you launch activities, we
have a scaling fading
animation.
Well, there's a lot of
movement in that.
If you're scaling out from zero
and you're fading in from
zero to all the way opaque,
you need to make it long
enough that it actually makes
sense and it's not stuttery
and discontinuous, because
it's trying to
cover a lot of distance.
But if we did a really long
duration, you would end up
waiting a long time for
that smooth animation.
It would be really annoying.
So what we do instead is we
start a really long animation
most of the way through.
I think it's like 80% of the way
opaque and 80% of the way
scaled out.
And then we finish
the animation.
So you get the implication of
a very great distance being
covered, but we do it in
small enough duration
that it's not annoying.
ROMAIN GUY: And what's very
interesting is that the
duration you choose will also
depend very much on what kind
of animation you're running.
The best example of that is if
you move something on screen.
If it's a small button, you can
use a very long duration,
and it will still feel
pretty good.
But if you use something that's
really big and really
large and you have the same
direction as with that small
item, that small button, it will
feel longer because the
object will feel heavier.
You can try that yourself.
Write an application and try to
move a really big rectangle
versus a small rectangle with
the same duration and the same
distance, in the feel will be
very different as a user.
CHET HAASE: That's actually why
Galileo did the experiment
with the stone and the feather,
because he was
testing animation durations.
Another important principle--
we'll try to bring up a lot of
classical science lessons
for you in this talk--
is to make your animations
smooth.
If you have a really complicated
animation that
does a lot of really cool stuff
and then it stutters in
the middle, your user
will hate you.
What you want is a
smooth experience
from start to finish.
Now sometimes it's not possible
for you to get all
the information that you need
to create the animation
without doing something like a
layout that might be a little
too expensive.
OK.
Two tips about that.
Don't run layout during
the animation.
We'll bring this up later just
to drive the point home.
And the other is go ahead and
run that layout or do that
expensive operation at
the beginning before
the animation starts.
When it's done, get the
information you need and then
start the animation.
And do whatever you can to keep
the animation running
smooth and performant for the
duration of the animation so
that that experience is
smooth to the user.
Otherwise, your animation's
going to get super annoying.
They're going to notice
the animation.
it because it's bad.
ROMAIN GUY: So performance--
we've talked about performance
in many other talks before--
is very, very important to
having smooth animations.
But it's not just about
performance.
If you change animations, the
way you're going to change the
animations, like the
acceleration curves you're
going to use, will also be very
important to keep the
animations smooth.
And I think we have an example
later on where we have a
bouncing button.
And if you don't do the bouncing
right, it will feel
like the animations
is stuttering.
It's not a performance issue.
It's just a timing issue.
So be also very careful
with how you tie
your animations together.
CHET HAASE: Here's another one
with a beautiful organic
picture behind it.
Make them feel natural.
Make the user not even notice
the animation because it just
feels like it needs
to be there.
This is the interaction that
makes sense for the
application, not just a whizzy
animation that you thought
looked cool at the time.
The idea is to allow the user
to interact with your
application in a way that they
enjoy and which feels very
organic and natural to them, not
which just feels cool to
the developer that happened to
write the whizzy animation.
And finally, you should
make your
applications not arbitrary.
One of my favorite examples, it
was some release of Linux?
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
On Linux Desktops, there was
something called Compiz or--
There are window managers that
when you close the window it's
really cool.
The window catches on
fire and disappears
in a burst of smoke.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
We could show you how to write
the code to do that.
Oh, also there was this
awesome application,
[? MyQuest 10. ?]
When you burn a CD, the
window would smoke.
There would smoke coming out
of the window like you're
burning the CD.
It's really cool.
Don't do it.
CHET HAASE: It's really
fun the first
time and after that--
ROMAIN GUY: There's one
situation where you can do it
is when you're on stage at the
conference and you show cool
stuff to people and then you
tell them to not do that.
CHET HAASE: We'll try to
do some of that today.
Don't do what we're doing.
Yes.
So make them make sense.
Give them a purpose.
Show the user what's going on
in the UI, indicate some
important action to them, help
them during transitions in the
experience, whatever.
There's a reason for the
animation to be there.
Make that be the reason
and not because you
thought it was cool.
So let's see a couple
of examples.
Actually, someone was just in
office hours a few minutes ago
asking, hey, I have a
quick question for
you if you have time.
What is the correct way to
do a ListView animation?
ROMAIN GUY: Here's the answer.
CHET HAASE: So we wrote some
quick code, and we developed
some slides.
So we thought we would show you
what we think would be the
correct way to do this.
A correct way do this.
The example here is we're going
to swipe an item out.
And as we swipe it,
it's doing a fade.
And you can see behind it we've
got a little backdrop
there, and we've got some
drop shadow there.
And then when we let go, it
moves the rest of the way off.
Or if you don't move
it enough, it
snaps back into place.
So we've got the animation
of the swipe.
And then after the item is gone,
if we swiped it out,
then the rest of the items
animate into place.
Fairly common for people
to want to do this.
Fairly common for people to not
understand how to do this.
So the interesting
part might be--
ROMAIN GUY: How many of you
have tried to do this?
How many of you have
failed to do it?
CHET HAASE: Come on.
Don't be shy.
ROMAIN GUY: Sorry about that.
It's mostly our fault.
CHET HAASE: OK.
ROMAIN GUY: So here's
the answer.
CHET HAASE: Let's take
a look at the code.
This might get a little bogged
down, because, of course,
there's a bunch of
code in there.
We have a callback of code on
the slide calling out the
important parts.
ROMAIN GUY: Is the form big
enough for everybody?
People in the back?
Or they don't care.
They're asleep.
OK.
CHET HAASE: They are asleep.
ROMAIN GUY: One guy said yes.
CHET HAASE: All right.
All right.
So here we are.
We are in ListView Removal
Animation.
Actually, I want to
take a look at the
ArrayAdapter first.
We create a stable ArrayAdapter,
because I don't
want my items to move
out from under me.
I don't want the content
to change.
So we will subclass ArrayAdapter
and return back
static item IDs.
That's important.
The other thing that we do in
this very simple subclass is
we set a listener, because I
want to track the motion on
each of the individual items as
we're swiping out, because
that's the indication that
we want to remove them.
ROMAIN GUY: The stable IDs is
a way for ListView to keep
track of what data belongs
to what row on screen.
It works without it.
But for this purpose, it's going
to be a lot easier with
stable IDs.
CHET HAASE: The
BackgroundContainer is where
we manage the graphics that
are going to draw the
background behind the item
that's being swept away as
well as the drop shadow in front
of that background to
sort of give the sense of depth,
the difference between
the layer that you're
swiping from and the
background behind it.
Now I could've, and did in the
first version of this, simply
have a background for
the ListView itself.
And then I ran some of the
overdraw tools that we talked
about in a previous
session today.
And I could see that, in fact,
we're drawing the background
and then we're drawing
all the list items.
That's a complete waste
of rendering time.
All I really wanted was a
background behind the item
that was going away.
So I did that.
So we have some code in here,
some initialization code that
creates two drop shadows.
This could also just be a single
9-patch that draws both
the upper and the lower drop
shadow in that space.
When we're told to show the
background, that trips a flag,
an we say, OK.
We're going to be drawing
stuff here.
Call our drawing routine.
And then we set up the area in
the container where we're
going to draw this
information.
On size change, we set
information about the shadows.
And then we override onDraw.
And in onDraw, we translate the
canvas where we need to.
We draw the background color.
We draw the drop shadows.
We're done.
But all the animation logic is
in ListView Removal Animation,
which is here.
I should point out too, I'm
going to be doing some
DevBytes episodes on these.
And we'll upload all of the
projects for the code that
you're going to see
here today.
So I'm going really quickly
through the code.
The code will eventually be
available so that you can
through it with better
quality time later.
OK.
So we have a bunch of choices.
We add them to the list.
We create our stable array
adapter, and we set the
adapter on the list.
All straightforward stuff
for ListView stuff.
onTouchListener, what we want
to do is track the action as
we're swiping, because we want
a little bit of not animated
behavior but different
drawing behavior.
We want to turn it translucent
as it swipes back and forth.
But most importantly, when we
lift our finger up, we want to
determine whether it's going to
snap back into place if we
didn't drag it far enough or
whether it's going to snap off
the screen.
So we calculate how far I
went before we let go.
And then we either snap it
back or snap it farther.
If we're snapping it off the
screen, then we're going to
animate the rest of
the way here.
So we're going to get a
ViewPropertyAnimator, and
we're going to animate the
alpha to all the way
transparent, and we're going to
animate translation to x.
So slide it all the way off.
And then when that animation
is done, so with an end
action, we're going to restore
some values here.
And then we're going to
animateOtherViews.
And that's where all
the magic happens.
So on to our next example.
No.
OK. animateOtherViews.
There's a couple of techniques
here which you're going to see
over and over again in these
examples, as well as some
other ones, where we
get information
before a layout happens.
And then we set a predraw
listener.
Then we get the information
from the views after the
layout occurred.
So we've already removed our
item from the adapter, which
means the layout is going to
run, and it's going to
reposition all the other views
in the layout according to the
change that just happened
in the ListView, right?
Standard ListView stuff.
What we want to do before
that layout happens--
this is synchronous--
we remove from the adapter, and
then immediately we go in
and we do two things.
We get information about where
each of those views is.
So where are you in the
current container?
And then we're going to store
that in a map here, and we'll
retrieve it later.
And we're also going to use a
property that's new in Jelly
Bean called transient state.
We're going to say
setHasTransientState true.
This is an important indicator
to ListView to not mess with
the view's content until I
set it to false again.
This is a ref counted
flag that we note.
And next time we go in to do
a recycling pass, we don't
recycle the views that have
this flag set on them.
And the reason this is important
for animating items
in ListViews is it means that
we're not going to change the
content in views that you may
be potentially moving around
on the screen.
If you don't set that
flag, who knows
what's going to happen?
In particular, what's going to
happen immediately, it's going
to run layout.
It's going to recycle
everything.
And it's going to repopulate
it in whatever
order it deemed necessary.
And that's probably not the
effect you're looking for.
So setHasTransientState true to
all of the views that are
currently in the ListView.
We set an OnPreDraw listener.
Layout is magically going to
run, because we're going to
return back to the UI thread.
And then before we draw the
results of that layout pass,
we're going to get a call to
our OnPreDraw function.
In here, we're going to remove
the PreDraw listener.
We don't want to
listen anymore.
And then we're going to go
in and find out where
everything is now.
This is where it used to be.
This is the cached value
that we had before.
This is where each
child is now.
We're going to find out
the difference.
We're going to calculate
the delta.
We're going to set that as the
translation Y property.
So basically, we knew
it came from here.
We know it's now there.
We're going to back translate it
to where it was before, and
we're going to animate zero.
So all we're doing is
backtranslating and then
animating to zero into the real
position that that view
occupies now.
The only other thing that we
need to do here is we need to
animate the new view that's
going to be coming in from the
bottom, or coming down
from on top.
We know where that
new view is now.
We just need to calculate where
we want it to appear
from, and then we slide that in
along with everything else.
When we're all done, we set
the hasTransientState to
false, and we're finished.
One other note about
TransientState,
ViewPropertyAnimator actually
sets this property
automatically.
So during a
ViewPropertyAnimation, you
views are safe.
They're not going to be recycled
out from under you.
The reason that we had to set it
manually, even in addition
to the ViewPropertyAnimator is
we didn't want to the views to
change during the layout pass,
which happens prior to the
animation that we run.
And that's it.
ROMAIN GUY: Was that clear?
You got all that?
We will give you the code.
CHET HAASE: I think
I've pretty much
walked through this.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
CHET HAASE: There you go.
It's like that.
ROMAIN GUY: New demo.
CHET HAASE: Easy.
All right.
Activity animations.
So here's another one that
has become common.
We have two things in the window
in activity changes
that are available to you.
One is the standard activity
animations that occur already.
You get fade-y, scale-y stuff
as activities launch.
And they scale and
fade into view.
That's fine.
And that's actually great
for an activity launch.
It's a nice consistent approach
to running any activity.
But let's say you're running a
subactivity and you want to do
something customized.
We also offer the ability to
customize window animations.
But it's very constrained
animations.
We added to that recently so
you could do a scale and a
cross-fade from a thumbnail
in Jelly Bean 4.2.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
4.1.
CHET HAASE: 4.1.
And that's great.
But you still can't really
customize that.
You can do exactly that
thumbnail scale, and you can't
scale back to the thumbnail,
for instance.
So there's sort of hard
limitations to what you can do
with window animations.
So the recommendation is--
ROMAIN GUY: We have
a trick for you.
So this is an animation.
And actually, Hugo Barra--
who you've seen at the keynote,
sitting right here--
told us it would be really
cool if we could do it.
And why is it not possible
to do it on Android?
And we're like, well,
of course we can.
So we did it.
Actually, Chet did it.
So I'm going to tap
on a picture.
And we'll animate from that
picture into a new activity.
So this is not just a view
that we put on top of the
first activity.
It's actually a new activity
that's showing details.
And we can go back and forth
between the two.
And let me slow down the
animation for you so you see
exactly what's happening.
There's a drop shadow.
We scale up the image, we
fade the background, and
we bring the text.
And it's actually pretty
easy to implement.
The trick is the new activity
is actually
a transparent activity.
And all the animations are view
animations inside that
transparent activity.
So we're going to take
a look at the code.
And it's going to be
a little easier.
Let's get rid of
all that stuff.
There we go.
So we have two activities.
We have Activity Animations.
That's the main activity
of the application.
And we have Picture
Details Activity.
And there's another interesting
class called
Shadow Layout.
We'll take a look at that
a little later.
So the main activity
doesn't do much.
It sets a grid.
We use a color matrix filter
to make all the images be
greyscale, because we also
animate from greyscale to
color when we scale
up the image.
Then we just set
up our adaptor.
So that's not very
interesting.
The interesting part is what
happens when you click on one
of the thumbnails.
So what we do is we're going
to start the next activity,
and we're going to add a lot of
extras to the intent that
we use to start the activity.
So what we want to send to the
new activity is the position
on screen of the thumbnail.
So to do this on View, there's
a method called
getLocationOnScreen.
You give it an array, and we're
going to fill the array
with the x and y position
of that view in screen
coordinates.
So it's not in parent
It's different from getLeft
and getTop.
It's not in window
coordinates.
There's another method
for that.
It's in screen coordinates.
We create our new intent.
We remembered your
orientation.
We'll talk about that later.
And then we store the
width and the
height of the thumbnail.
We store the position
on screen.
We store the resource idea of
the thumbnail, like what big
image should we be showing, as
well as the description.
And finally, at the end,
we call this method
overridePendingTransitions.
And by pressing 00, we tell the
Window Manager that we do
not want a new window
animation.
We're going to take care of
everything, and we're going to
do our view animations.
So then we launch the Picture
Details activity.
An in onCreate, we just extract
all the data we need
from the bundle in the intent.
And here's what happens when
we run the animation.
So we checked the
savedInstanceState.
So if we have a
savedInstanceState, that means
there was a configuration
change.
And most of the time, it's
going to be a rotation.
In that case, we do not want
to run the animation again.
So we only run the animation
when the first time we bring
up the activity.
So the savedInstanceState
is null.
So we set the viewTreeObserver.
And the viewTreeObserver--
sorry--
will use an [INAUDIBLE]
listener.
Because we're on the onCreate
method, that callback will be
invoked before we draw the
first frame but after the
layout, so after all the items
are positioned in the window.
So they have their widths, they
have their height, and
they have their position.
First thing we do is we remove
the listener because we don't
need it anymore.
And then we had our image with
the big version of the image.
It's not the thumbnail
anymore.
We're in the new activity.
And we do what we've done in
the previous activity.
We look at the location on
screen of the image.
So we know where we came from
the previous activity in the
intent, and we know where
we want to go.
We also compute the
scale factor.
So what is the difference in
size between the big version
of the image and the
small thumbnail?
And finally, we start
our animation.
The animation itself
is very simple.
We have our image that's been
laid out at its final size, so
it's taking most of the
space on screen.
We change its position and its
scale so that it matches
exactly the position
of the thumbnail in
the previous activity.
And remember, because we're a
transparent activity, it will
look like we're in the
same activity.
The text is a special case.
We make it invisible.
And then, all we do is we
animate the ImageView, and we
tell it to scale back to its
normal size, so 100% scale x
and scale y and 0 for
the translation.
At the end of the animation, we
just animate the text, but
just for the nice effect.
We have secondary animations.
And we're going to talk
about secondary
animations a little later.
But we fade in the
black background.
We turn the image from greyscale
to colors, and we're
going to show you
how to do this.
As you can see here, we're
modifying a property called
Saturation on our
own activity.
So we've created a
custom property.
It's not a feature of view.
It's not a future
of the UI token.
It's something we've
built ourselves.
And you're going to see, if
you've never done that, it's
extremely simple to create
your own properties.
And we'll also animate the
shadow of the picture.
We have this property
called shadowDepth
on our shadow layout.
And here is our custom
property.
So we need a setSaturation
method We also have a
getSaturation method.
And all we do is we change the
situation in our color matrix,
we create a new filter, and we
set that filter on the image.
And you're automatically going
to get that nice greyscale to
color effect.
One interesting trick
here is that we
override the finish method.
CHET HAASE: Specifically
for the
overridePendingTransitions.
Because, like we did on the way
in, we don't want to run
window animations and have them
get in the way and be
parallel to the things that
we're trying to do in our
customized activity
animations.
So as soon as we're actually
finishing, then we
overridePendingTransitions,
window animations get out of
the way, and we customize
the return
back to the main activity.
ROMAIN GUY: And we also trap
the Back key events.
So when the Back key is pressed,
by default we're
going to finish the activity.
That's the default behavior
of the Toolkit.
Here, we're prevented
from doing that.
What we want is we first want
to run our animations.
So we call runExitAnimation,
which is very similar to the
animation we saw for the
enter animation.
And at the end of the exit
animation, we're going to
execute this runable, and
it's just going to
call the finish method.
Do you want to show
the shadow layout?
CHET HAASE: Sure.
So shadow layout, is it's a
very simple view group.
I wanted the ability for a
container to put shadows
behind all of its children.
It has one property, which is
the depth, which gets animated
over time as that thumbnail
scales into the nice colorized
large version of the picture.
And as that animates,
it's going to
animate its depth property.
The depth property is then used
to determine two things
about the shadow,
the opacity--
so we're going to be
animating alpha--
as well as the offsets.
So we're basically going to draw
a shadow that gets larger
and more translucent as the
image comes into place in its
large version.
We're going to set up the
shadow itself here.
Some rendering details
about creating a
nice blurred shadow.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
We don't have much time
to talk about it.
CHET HAASE: OK.
ROMAIN GUY: But if you're
interested in how to create a
blurry shadow without
using a 9-patch--
You could be using a 9-patch.
That's a great way of doing
it, if you want to do it
programmatically.
You can refer to that
piece of code here.
CHET HAASE: We set the
shadow depth here.
This is called by
the animation.
Then we invalidate when the
depth is change so that we'll
actually redraw this
container.
And then we override on draw,
which processes through all
the children of this
container.
In this case, there's just one,
and it draws the shadow
appropriately.
All right.
This is callouts to the
various details there.
I think we went through
enough details on how
to make that work.
Again, the slides and the code
will be posted later for the
real details.
We also wanted to talk about
some cartoon animation
techniques.
It turns out that there were
some people back in the '20s
and '30s and Disney who thought
really hard about how
to make engaging animations.
And they had a couple of very
important constraints that
were important to them and are
still important to us, which
is there's a very little
amount of time and a
potentially complex scene on the
screen which the user has
to understand.
They developed these 12
principles of animation.
And a lot of them focus around
focusing the user's attention
on exactly what they need them
to understand, simplifying
that action as much as possible,
and indicating and
exaggerating around that action
so that they can get
all the information to quickly
understand the important
information about exactly
how Mickey was
running on the screen.
ROMAIN GUY: So we're not going
to talk about all the
principles of cartoon
animations, because they don't
all apply to UIs.
And there's a lot of overlap
between the different
techniques.
But we're going to show
you a few of them.
And we'll have demos showing you
how to implement those in
your applications.
So the first one is squash
and stretch.
And remember, one of the
principles of good animations
is that your animation
should feel natural.
And this is one way of making
your animations feel natural.
When you move something, instead
of just moving the
object, you can try to elongate
the object to squash
it and stretch it, pretty much,
to give it this more
natural feel.
This is not quite what
happens in real life.
But I'm sure you've all seen
cartoons where someone kicks
in a soccer bowl and the
soccer ball becomes an
ellipse, pretty much.
And this is something that we
can do very easily in our UIs.
CHET HAASE: Another important
principle is timing.
And this refers to a couple of
different elements of timing.
There's a non-linear timing,
which is important for
conveying natural motion.
People and objects in our real
world don't move linearly.
You don't start at the speed
that you're going to be
traveling the entire time
linearly and then stop
immediately.
Instead, you accelerate into a
pace and decelerate out of it,
in general, unless
you hit a wall.
ROMAIN GUY: Or if you're
really weird.
CHET HAASE: Unless you're
really weird or a robot.
The other important element of
timing is to choose timing
that is appropriate
to the action.
We talked about short durations
before, the
animations being as short
as they need to be.
But there's other elements
of duration as well.
As Steve Martin said,
the important
thing here is timing.
So let's take a look at a
quick demo of squash and
stretch and a little
bit of code.
So the idea here is you click
the button, and we're going to
bounce it off the bottom
of the screen.
We can slow that down
so you can see
what's actually happening.
So there's a couple of things.
The down animation is a little
more subtle than you might
have suspected at first.
You can see it's actually
elongating a little
bit on the way down.
It's very subtle, but you kind
of pick up that change.
And it gives the indication that
this button is actually
kind of a rubbery material that
changes and is affected
by gravity is also affected
by hitting the floor.
Maybe not something you want
to do in your UIs.
I would not recommend
it, in general.
But in some situations, adding
a little bit of organic
properties to an object
is appropriate.
ROMAIN GUY: Actually, we'll
have an example of an
application on the Play Store,
a pretty serious application
that uses some of these
animation techniques.
CHET HAASE: So actually, the
code for this, it's basically
the same details
over and over.
This is just a sequenced
animation
where we run it down.
We run a reversing animation,
and squashes and stretches
out, squashes and stretches
back, and then
it runs back up.
And this is just pure
application of
PropertyValuesHolder creating an
ObjectAnimator object that
can animate multiple properties
at the same time.
We set specific interpolaters
to get an accelerated feel
down, to get a deceleration
feel as it squashes and
stretches, and then the
reverse behavior on
the way back up.
We stretch.
It's just the same thing
over and over again.
PropertyValuesHolder,
ObjectAnimator,
they're your friend.
We repeat the animation on the
squash and the stretch, and we
set the duration very carefully
to sort of give the
right feeling between all these
different dynamics here.
And then we create an animator
set to run these different
animations sequentially.
Pretty straightforward.
Moving on.
Next principle, anticipation.
This was important for the
animators to indicate what was
about to happen.
ROMAIN GUY: For instance, if I
want to punch Chet, I will
start by doing this.
CHET HAASE: And I might
If Mickey is about to run, he
wouldn't just start running.
Instead, he would rear
back and run.
And this was an important
indicator to the viewer that
something was about to happen,
a running action
was about to happen.
So when it actually happened,
they would be clued into that
exactly going on, instead of he
runs, he's off the screen
immediately, they blinked in
that instant, and they don't
know where Mickey went.
So anticipation can be used to
help the user understand an
action that is about to occur.
So if we switch over
to the demo--
So That's right.
I was going to run this
on the next one.
So we have this AnticiButton.
This is a custom button.
There's a couple of different
things going on here.
One is the anticipation.
As I click on it, it's rearing
back, indicating that it's
going to do that run to the
other side of the screen.
So when I release it, then
it actually moves.
And then when it hits the other
side it's going to do
the other principle that we're
going to talk about on the
next slide.
ROMAIN GUY: So this is the
source code for this demo.
So before we run the animation,
we need a way to be
able to do that deformation
on the button.
It's actually very easy to do.
We have our custom
class right here.
So we extend the button class.
We are a small constructor.
Structure just set the
ClickListener.
We also set a TouchListener,
because what we want to do is
on the down event we want
to be able to start the
anticipation, and on the
up event we want to
run our click animation.
So to do this skew here we're
going to do something that I
said it was not possible
yesterday.
CHET HAASE: He lied.
ROMAIN GUY: No.
I was misguided.
I misremembered.
The draw method is not final.
You can override it.
But if you do, make sure you
call the super.draw method.
CHET HAASE: And point of fact,
it's the only way that you can
do this effect on
some widgets.
You can do the skew effect on
a TextView by overriding on
draw, which is a safer
thing to override.
But you actually need to
override draw for the button,
because that's where some of the
stuff happens that you--
ROMAIN GUY: For instance,
the background.
CHET HAASE: Right.
ROMAIN GUY: So the
implementation is pretty simple.
We have our canvas.
We have a skew factor.
That's what we're going
to animate.
And we just call the
canvas.skew method.
So you don't have much to do.
The translation here is just so
that we can do this skew in
the right place.
And then we call the
super.draw method.
Then, when we run the
click animation--
Let's see.
No.
We have the anticipation
animation first.
So on the down event, when you
push the button, we want to
start doing the anticipation.
So this is where we run
this animation.
So we just skew to the left.
It's a normal animation.
And if you let go of the button
and the animation is
not over, we're going to finish
this animation when I
cancel it and go back
to the origin.
And then when we let go, we're
going to create the move
animation, so we're going to
have it translate the button.
And at the same time,
we want to do the
overshoot at the end.
So when we reach the end of the
animation, we're going to
skew to the left and skew to
the right back and forth.
And the easiest way to do it is
to use something called the
overshoot interpolater.
So if you look at the
interpolation curves, a linear
curve is just a straight line.
We also have the accelerate
and decelerate curves.
They look like S's or like an
F. And the overshoot looks
like, basically, a bounce.
So this wobble effect, there's
nothing for you to do.
All you do is you animate
this skewx.
You set the overshoot
interpolater on the animation,
and that's what's
going to happen.
And finally, we use an animator
set to sequence all
this animation.
So we're going to do the move.
We're going to do the skew
at the end when we
run against the wall.
And then we're going
to run the wobble.
CHET HAASE: So next principle,
which you also saw in that
demo, is follow through and
overlapping action.
When the button hits the
right-hand side, we want it to
have this feeling that
it actually is a
more organic material.
So when it hits that wall, it
can't just stop immediately.
Instead, part of it
would carry on.
When we hit a wall, then part
of our body will not hit the
wall all at the same
time and not stop.
Instead, it's going to
wrap around the solid
parts that did stop.
So how can you indicate
that with a button?
Well, we actually continued
the skew.
So as soon as it stops on the
right, the skew continues and
goes past, indicating that may
be it had a little too much
for lunch and it's going to
carry on where the rest of the
button stopped.
And then once it gets to that
final point, then it's going
to wobble back to
the end point.
So we saw that demo.
I think we're going to skip
the live button demo.
It was another thing
about anticipation.
Instead, we're going to
do non-linear motion.
We'll show the demo.
This actually comes from code
that I posted on my blog,
curved animation in Android.
So we'll post to DevBytes
about this as well.
But I'll save the code for the
article for doing this.
The idea here is that we want
to be able to move things
naturally on the screen.
Just like timing shouldn't be
linear, in general motion
shouldn't be linear either.
There's a more natural feel to
things settling into place,
which is not moving
in a direct line.
It's moving like people and real
things in the world move.
So sometimes curved motion
make sense instead.
And as I said, we'll skip
that code for now.
Let me talk a little bit
about exaggeration.
And that's another technique
that the original animators
used to help indicate
what was going on.
If you're going to have a big
nose, make it a really big
nose, indicate that this
is one honking schnoz.
You want to make everything
bigger than life to help the
user understand things even
clearer and more quickly than
they would otherwise.
And in animation, that can help
as well to exaggerate
behavior, to either make things
sort of hyperreal or
just hyper accentuate what's
going on to help them
understand quickly
what's happening.
For this, we're going
to run a demo.
Again, I'm not going to go into
the code on this, because
there's a lot of code.
There's a lot of different
pieces.
We've actually seen all the
different elements of this
throughout the other
little microdemos.
We've got custom activity
animations as we launch from
this activity into
the next one.
So that's actually going
into a subactivity.
We didn't use window
animations.
We used custom activity
animations where we came in
immediately with the white
background and then animated
the elements in that view.
We have a couple of different
things going on here.
One is that the buttons actually
popped in, so they
sort of did an overshoot as they
faded and popped onto the
screen, to give a feeling of
engagement, some feeling of
fun to the kid that they want
to attract and engage in the
application.
They want to be very
interactive.
And then the text skews
to give that
anticipation feeling.
Engagement is very important
in monetization.
ROMAIN GUY: What's the number?
CHET HAASE: So that's
the entire activity.
We won't enter the credit
card right now.
But another one is just you've
got the button there.
You know what?
You really want the kid
to start playing.
So this is a little bit funny.
We're probably not all writing
cartoon applications, and it
may be easy to write this off.
But we've actually seen cartoon
effects in other
applications, again, used for
the idea of engagement, of
being fun, of being attractive,
and being
enjoyable to use.
So here's the Path
application.
ROMAIN GUY: In this application,
look, there's my
avatar right here.
Focus on the little circle
just under the avatar.
So I'm going to start scrolling
the list, and you
can see there's this
anticipation.
It's stretching and stretching
and stretching.
There's the wobble.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
It stretches organically, just
like our button did when it
squashed and stretched.
And then it snapped down.
And it didn't just
snap into place.
It did a wobble.
So it's got this feeling that
it's rubbery, it's organic,
and, even more so, it's fun.
ROMAIN GUY: You know,
that animation is
pretty annoying, actually.
CHET HAASE: Doesn't it make
you want to enter a credit
card, though?
It does me.
ROMAIN GUY: It makes me want
to turn off the phone.
CHET HAASE: All right.
Some quick tips here.
We've seen some of these
along the way.
It's worth calling them out.
ROMAIN GUY: Really quick.
CHET HAASE: Very quick tips,
in 1 minute and 32.
Avoid layout.
If you want to have smooth
animations, don't run layout
on every frame.
We've seen people trying
to do ListView
animations with this approach.
Sometimes that's the only
way to accomplish it.
But frankly, if you can't run
the animation smoothly because
it's doing too much work, such
as laying out a really complex
container, maybe an animation is
not the right solution for
that problem.
Avoid layout.
If you have to run layout to get
the after positions that
you're going to animate
into, that's fine.
Run layout.
Then run your animation.
Make sure you don't run layout
during the animation.
ROMAIN GUY: But it's pretty much
guaranteed that if you
run a layout on every frame
your animation will be
stuttering.
ViewTreeObserver, you
saw it real briefly.
If you don't know about this
class, I really encourage you
to take a look at it.
It can be used to
listen to global
events in the view hierarchy.
So you can get an event when we
are about to draw a frame.
You can get an event when we're
about to layout a frame.
You can also know when the
touch mode has changed.
So if you have a device with a
keyboard, you'll be notified
when the keyboard becomes active
versus the touchscreen.
There's global focus changes.
A lot of very useful information
comes from the
ViewTreeObserver.
And we actually use it quite
a bit internally.
CHET HAASE: And layers is more
of a performance tip.
If you have a complex view or a
complex view hierarchy that
you want to animate, consider
setting a hardware layer on it
during the animation.
Don't set a layer on something
that is actually changing,
because we're going to
have to recreate that
layer on every frame.
But do set it on a complex view
whose alpha that you want
to animate or that you want to
translate on the screen.
ROMAIN GUY: So if you want to
know more, we gave a talk
called "Animation Rules"
at Devoxx 2009.
It's available online
at parleys.com.
Chet has an awesome series of
DevBytes on YouTube about
animations.
You can also check out "The
Illusion of Life".
It's the book that we
are referring to.
It's a great book, if you manage
to carry it back home,
because it's pretty big.
CHET HAASE: It's a coffee
table book.
It is the size of
a coffee table.
ROMAIN GUY: I use it as a
coffee table, actually.
No.
It's a fantastic book.
It's very interesting.
The parts about the principal of
animation is really short,
but there's a great history of
Disney and how they came up
with all those fantastic
cartoons.
So check it out.
Our websites.
And we're out of time.
So if you have questions for us,
we'll be at the Sandbox--
CHET HAASE: After the
fireside chat.
ROMAIN GUY: --after
the fireside chat.
Yes.
There's that.
And before you exit the room,
if you want to rate this
session, you can scan the
QR codes by the doors.
Thank you very much.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.